on the eve of idle atha it's like
everyone is leaving the bangladeshi
capital dhaka millions of people are
trying to return to their home villages
to celebrate with family
but trains are already packed
yesterday evening we failed to board a
train as too many people had rushed onto
it today we have come again to try but
we are not sure we will be able to get
into a train we are just thinking about
whether we will take the roof but we are
together with children how can we go
just feeling hopeless
others try their luck here with fairies
facing the same problem
there was too much rush to board the
ferry so there was no option but to take
to the roof it has taken so much trouble
is one of the largest religious
festivals in bangladesh people spend
most of the year saving for this day
they time their vacations to coincide
with it and can't fail to join family
and to buy new clothes and gifts
most importantly they have to buy a
healthy animal to slaughter in keeping
with tradition
it's a good opportunity for cattle
dealers
i've come with three of my own cows and
have come to sell them in this market
for eid the whole year i've taken care
of them and hoped to make some profit
prices usually go up ahead of the eid
festival and this year they hit a record
but people have no choice but to buy the
animals
i just bought one boat to sacrifice in
the name of god for eid for which i paid
for with two hundred thousand taka
that's more than two thousand dollars
and still considered a reasonable
al jazeera